c'est pas totalement faux mais non je
dors pas avec une bouillotte non non non
je reprends faux nom je l' empêche le
mougeotte mais par contre je me serve
une bouillotte de temps en temps
ah oui et pas n'importe quelle mug bah
ouais j'ai rencontré la mère de mes
enfants sur le jeu d'enfant mbaye
c'était marion ouest une belle rencontre
sacrée rencontre
n'en faut je n'ai pas fait la coiffure
par contre j'ai fait du pain parfois des
fois sur le tournage donc tu vois quand
même j'ai voulu participer comme
activement au tournage
ah bon
ah ouais
ouais en la vache ah oui ça
m'impressionne j'ai vu qu'il y avait
plein qui vendait des iphone
sur leur compte en mon nom a way la fage
[ __ ] ça s'arrête pas bah j'espère que
les gens se font pas trop à voir
avec avec ses faux comptes
guitton guitton guitou guillaume
guillaume j'ai un peu tout par mes potes
ah oui enfin relancer le commerce des
huîtres pour joël dupuch surfaite
quitterait l'ostréiculteur
un but
assez vrai assez cool merci parce que je
sais parce que j'étais comme aux pros
chinois bah c'est vrai alors super un
buffle ok bah je suis bélier en signe
astrologique donc j'ai pas mal de cornes
quand même ouais donc je fonçais je
réfléchis après en fait ça me correspond
pas plutôt pas mal en fait
ces fossés fois que j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup de suite et à cheval d'ailleurs
c'est pas hasard tu vois si je suis
assis en tailleur du côté gauche c'est
pas du côté droit je me suis tout péter
à droite
ça c'est vrai ouais ouais ouais je
réfléchis trop je réfléchis trop ça me
conduit à faire des films comme lui et
apprend bien là bien bien la tête
alors ça je ne sais pas c'est pas si
c'est vrai peut-être que c'est comme ça
qu'on nous appelle je peux pas dire si
c'est vrai
non c'est faux par contre j'adore faire
le crumble à la pomme et je pense que
c'est le seul truc que je sache faire
avec le pain je vais faire le crumble et
du pain
lui n'est pas que un connard mais lui un
connard en lui en fait c'est le thème du
film en fait c'est de savoir est ce
qu'on n'est pas tous un petit peu comme
ça ce qu'on n'a pas tous un côté un peu
double avec une cette petite voix des
fois qui peut nous faire chier
non c'est faux mais je suis pas non plus
un mauvais mauvais perdant
ça c'est vrai je sais pas comment tu
sais ça mais je pense que je suis pas le
seul c'est ça c'est très chiant je peux
passer des heures à regarder sur toutes
les plateformes et jaquette de films et
de regarder les résumés en fait un bout
d'un moment il est tard et je me dis moi
y est d'accord un char gardien puis
c'est tout
j'ai un conte de quoi au nifff and honey
fans c'est quoi ça what
cette histoire j'ai quoi gerin chez moi
j'ai un compte à moi que j'utilise bah
ouais c'est vrai non mais c'est pas vrai
évidemment que évident a évidemment que
c'est pas vrai
non non j'ai pas menti non non j'ai
franchement je ne crois pas